stahlbrücken
spektakuläre konstruktionen die die
landschaft prägen sie überspannen nicht
nur wasser oder täler
in luftiger höhe überwinden sie andere
straßen ortschaften oder
naturschutzgebiete wo sie erbaut wurden
sind sie nicht mehr wegzudenken
abertausende menschen nutzen sie täglich
und sparen dadurch viel zeit doch der
rohstoff aus dem sie bestehen macht sie
enorm anfällig täglich müssen die
giganten unter schwierigsten bedingungen
gewartet werden
wer schon einfach nicht runter und
machen unsere arbeit wir haben keine
angst
egal wo egal wie die wartung der
stahlbrücken ist fast immer eine
risikoreiche gradmann wenn es das
schlimmste
der bau einer stahlbrücke ist eine große
herausforderung
ein multi millionen spiel das von den
erbauern und ingenieuren starke nerven
fordert
[Applaus]
warum sollte man damals eine 40
millionen dollar begann der bau der
gigantischen
konstruktionen überschreitet grenzen und
fordert menschenleben wir haben 16 leute
verloren 16 leute sind beim bau der
brücke gestorben
ein wettlauf gegen die zeit mit höhen
und tiefen
doch der aufwand und das risiko lohnen
sich
da ist teil der geschichte davon kannst
du deinen kindern und enkeln erzählen
in dieser dokumentation führen wir sie
hinter die kulissen und zeigen ihnen die
geheimnisse der gigantischen
konstruktion vom bau der stahlbrücken
bis zur aufwändigen wartung
[Musik]
majestätisch
einzigartig
gigantisch
brücken faszinieren die menschen schon
seit jahrtausenden
was mit einem umgestürzten baum über
eine kleine schlucht anfing ist heute zu
kilometer langen komplizierten
konstruktionen aus stahl geworden die
industrielle produktion von stahl begann
mitte des 19 jahrhunderts
einige jahrzehnte später wurden die
ersten schweren stahl brücken gebaut
danach folgt eine ära großer
bogenbrücken
aber die belastung nimmt stetig zu immer
mehr züge autos und lkw nutzen den
kürzeren weg ingenieure auf der ganzen
welt wagen sich daher an immer größere
aufgaben heran um diese gigantischen
bauwerke zu schaffen
die sydney harbour bridge das
wahrzeichen eines ganzen kontinents und
eine der meist besuchten
sehenswürdigkeiten
australiens
dazu ist sie der wichtigste
verkehrsknotenpunkt des landes
1926 begannen die bauarbeiten
kompliziert und gefährlich für alle
beteiligten denn eine rund 500 meter
breite wasserstraße musst du überbrückt
werden
selbst heute stellt die brücke die
männer die auf ihr arbeiten täglich vor
große herausforderungen
24 stunden am tag sieben tage die woche
das ist ein harter job der ganz
besonders belohnt wird du bist teil der
geschichte davon kannst du deinen
kindern und enkeln erzählen die sydney
harbour bridge wurde nach achteinhalb
jahren
1932 feierlich eröffnet
sie ragt 134 meter in die höhe mit einer
spannweite von 503 metern
sie überspannt den hafen von sydney im
südosten australiens
das panorama ist weltberühmt die
imposante skyline mit den zwei
wahrzeichen
zum einen das sydney opera house der
jüngere geniestreich und eben die sydney
harbour bridge
sie ist die hauptverbindung zwischen
sydneys nord und süd küste täglich
bringt die steinernen bogenbrücke knapp
160000 autos von a nach b sie ist eine
der größten und mit 49 metern auch eine
der breitesten stahlbrücken der welt auf
ihr haben insgesamt acht straßen spuren
zwei bahngleise ein fahrradweg und ein
fußweg platz
süd tower früher morgen
insgesamt arbeiten über 100 mitarbeiter
am erhalt der brücke für die frühschicht
steht gerade das vorgeschriebene
sicherheitsprüfung durch den teamleiter
an er arbeitet in köln ihr verwendet
sicherheitsgurte schickt sie wagt euch
ein am verankerung punkt zur stetig line
schickt sie vertraut niemandem nur euch
selbst an die jungs in den hebebühnen
checkt die hebebühnen füllt die
logbücher aus wenn sie voll sind sagt
uns bescheid
die brücken malen lemmy und massimo
gehören seit jahren zur festen
alleine lennys seit über 25 jahren dabei
um keine routine und damit eine mögliche
fehlerquelle aufkommen zu lassen werden
die teams jeden tag neu zusammen
erstellt
dank arbeitet sicher
lenny und massimo sind heute für den
anstrich oben auf der brücke eingeteilt
nicht irgendwo oben sondern ganz oben
auf der spitze der harbour bridge
ihr weg führt direkt raus aus dem
südteil der als lager und sammelstelle
dient
kurioserweise ist dass auch die einzige
funktion der tower denn sie sind reine
designelemente der architekten
statisch gesehen sind sie völlig
verzichtbar die fahrbahn ist über
hunderte kabel vom bogen der brücke
abgehängt der stahlbogen mündet in ein
massives fundament aus 95 1000
kubikmetern beton
über 500 meter wasserstraße überwinden
und mit einer enormen brücken höhe
weiterhin schifffahrt möglich machen
schien lange unmöglich
mit einer geschickten konstruktion und
einem 39.000 tonnen schweren stahlbogen
haben es die ingenieure in sydney
geschafft 80 prozent des stahls wurde
damals eigens aus england importiert
massimo und lenny auf dem weg zum
obersten punkt der brücke
eine atemberaubende aussicht auch nach
dem x-ten aufstieg es ist echt ein
privileg hier oben zu sein du schätzt
den ausblick auf den hafen wenn du hier
hoch läuft es ist einfach wunderschön
das ist echt krass schau dir an wie gut
das ist manchmal arbeitest du hier
schaut hoch und denkst dir wow du
vergisst einfach wie geil das ist
mehrere teams arbeiten täglich parallel
am erhalt der brücke
die sind eh harbour bridge ist mit ihren
500 drei metern spannweite ein wahrer
touristenmagnet
2,5 millionen menschen kommen jährlich
in die australische metropole die
harbour bridge ist ein begehrtes foto
motiv
[Musik]
ingenieur war oder karachi ist eine der
haupt manager der sydney harbour bridge
er kam für sein studium nach sydney und
weiß wie wichtig die brücke für die
stadt ist
menschen auf der ganzen welt
identifizieren city mit der harbour
bridge
es kommen tausende menschen nur wegen
der brücke her
sie kommen zu uns um über die brücke zu
sprechen
für die meisten ist sie keine transport
verbindung sondern eher eine ikone darum
lieben die menschen
wie sehr die menschen von der brücke
fasziniert sind zeigt der sogenannte
bridge climb für fast 200 euro pro
person können touristen im rahmen einer
geführten tour auch die brücke steigen
die tour ist in der hauptsaison beinahe
komplett ausgebucht
für massimo und lenny ist der ausblick
umsonst ihr job heute auf der westseite
der brücke den stahl vom rost befreien
frische grundierung auftragen und
lackieren bei 485 1000 quadratmetern
stahl eigentlich eine never ending story
die fast zehn jahre dauert sobald die
maler cruz einmal durch sind beginnt die
arbeit von 9
eines muss jeder arbeiter auf der brücke
unbedingt sein schwindelfrei auch wenn
der job mit den jahren immer sicherer
geworden ist
und man darf nie vergessen dass während
des baus der sydney harbour bridge 16
menschen ihr leben gelassen haben 16
männer sind gestorben beim bau dieser
brücke
seitdem die brücke gewartet wird 1932 33
haben wir niemanden verloren
nach achteinhalb jahren bauzeit wird die
brücke am 19 märz 1932 eröffnet
doch der preis ist hoch von den 1400
männern die auf dem bau gearbeitet haben
verunglücken 16 tödlich eine tragödie
die untrennbar mit der brücke verbunden
ist
die sydney harbour bridge wurde während
der weltwirtschaftskrise aber das war zu
einer zeit in der die konstruktion der
brücke sehr wichtig war weil hier
tausende arbeitsplätze geschaffen hat
leider haben einige arbeitet das mit
ihrem leben bezahlt diese menschen sehen
wir als helden an weil es die brücke
gebaut haben das sind die menschen die
die anerkennung verdienen dass wir
mitten in sydney solch ein fabelhaftes
bauwerk haben
das andenken an die verunglückten
arbeiter halten die männer der wartungs
cruz bis heute hoch besonders leni
sonst
mwst
16 der
salzburger habe
da
ich habe diesen song selbst geschrieben
er heißt one step down und ich habe
dieses lied über die 16 männer
geschrieben die während des baus
verstorben sind das ist ein richtig
guter song ich muss schon sagen der
super das hat er echt gut gemacht
massimo trägt als nächstes die
grundierung auf den frisch geschliffenen
starrlauf für den anstrich der gesamten
brücke sind fast 30.000 liter farbe
nötig die farbe ist eine
sonderanfertigung und wird eigens für
die harbour bridge produziert
australiens ganze stolz hat den
täglichen anstrich auch bitter nötig die
alle stahlbrücken die von salzhaltiger
meeresluft umgeben sind ist auch die
sydney harbour bridge extrem korrosions
anfällig überall wo sich löcher in farb
kleid zeigen schlägt der rost
unerbittlich zu deswegen versuchen rené
und massimo immer einen tick schneller
zu sein und freuen sich wenn es klappt
so sieht es aus wenn ihr fertig sind das
hat mich und lenny zuletzt gemacht mit
vier fünf jungs zusammen so sieht es
dann aus das ist dann die farbe die nur
für die sydney harbour bridge gemacht
hat
beide wissen nach dem anstrich ist vor
dem anstrich trotzdem lieben sie den job
es könnte nicht besser sein ich liebe
meine stadt
ich selbst und die anderen jungs wir
sind einfach teil der geschichte
das werden wir nie vergessen
die gewaltige dimension und die
einzigartige lage neben dem
weltberühmten opernhaus machen die
sydney harbour bridge zu einer der
fotogen ssten stahlbrücken der welt
indien kalkutta in den 30er jahren des
letzten jahrhunderts beginnt hier der
bau der fabrik heute eine der
meistfrequentierten drücken der welt und
ein tonnenschwerer stahlgigant nach
sechs jahren bauzeit wer die stahlbrücke
1943 eröffnet
[Musik]
die harbour bridge steht im osten
indiens und verbindet die
millionenmetropole kalkutta und aura
der überbau der brücke besteht aus über
26.000 tonnen stahl die großteile des
stahls kommen aus indischen fabriken
lediglich die komplexen verbindungen
wurden aus england importiert die
insgesamt 705 meter lange
stahlkonstruktion ist eine der größten
ausleger brücken der welt
die wartung des giganten ist immer ein
gefährlicher und ungesicherter kletter
akt
in der millionenmetropole kalkutta ist
die hora bridge eines der nadelöhre der
stadt die brücke ist eine der letzten
großen stahl ausleger brücken der welt
hier rauscht alles drüber was laufen
oder fahren kann
ursprünglich sollte die brücke für autos
und einer straßenbahn linie dienen durch
den immer steigenden verkehr wird die
brücke heute ausschließlich von autos
lkw und fußgängern genutzt
eine teilsperrung der brücke würde einen
mega verkehrs kollaps auslösen damit die
brücke stets befahrbar bleibt ist das
wartungsteam um teamchef tätig jeden tag
mit dem erhalt der brücke beschäftigt
[Musik]
die wartung ist für uns routine auch die
höhe macht uns nichts
los geht's
der tägliche aufstieg arbeitsalltag für
das team 50 meter über dem fließenden
verkehr ein balance akt auf blanken
stahlträgern
das inspektions team trägt zwar
klettergurte doch aus zeitgründen und
weil es oftmals schlichtweg gar keine
möglichkeit gibt sich an zu
gartenarbeiten die männer lieber ohne
gurte
ich habe keine probleme herunter zu
schauen wir gehen hoch und sind auf
unsere arbeit konzentriert dann schauen
wir einfach nicht runter und machen
unseren job wir haben keine angst für
uns überhaupt kein problem die
vogelnester zu entfernen
tatsächlich sind vögel das hauptproblem
genauer gesagt vogelkot er verursacht
korrosionsschäden die vögel leben
massenhaft auf der brücke weil sie vom
abfall unter der brücke angelockt werden
denn auf neben und unter der brücke
haben hunderte menschen ihre märkte und
zelte aufgeschlagen
der größte teil der einwohner kalkuttas
lebt immer noch in armut deren abfälle
sind ein gefundenes fressen für vögel
die sich im stahlgerüst der brücke ihre
nester bauen
da oben ist ein nest
jeden tag aufs neue müssen die männer
der erwartungs crew vogelnester aus der
stahl konstruktion der brücke entfernen
[Applaus]
ein waghalsiger kletter akt es gibt
keinerlei absicherung jeder falsche
schritt ist tödlich doch zum glück gab
es bei den wartungsarbeiten angeblich
noch keinen einzigen schlimmeren unfall
[Musik]
das nicht muss ziemlich neu gewesen sein
ganz oben im gerüst jetzt haben wir es
entfernt den stall sauber gemacht und
schmeißen das jetzt weg
zu dem lästigen problem mit dem vogel
kurz kommt noch eine weitere
schwierigkeit
gotthards accra botti security manager
der brücke kennt sie nur allzu gut und
kämpft seit jahren gegen ein sicher
weltweit einmaliges problem beim erhalt
einer stahlbrücke
die brücke hat mit menschlichen
gewohnheiten zu kämpfen eine
angewohnheit von indern und ich
verurteile das gar nicht ich liebe
indische angewohnheiten und es ist
einfach die macht der gewohnheit müsse
zu essen und sie hin zu spucken wo immer
du kannst
daher haben wir hier mit einem sicher
einzigartigen korrosions problem zu tun
denn wir haben schlichtweg asiens
probleme mit der brücke die einfach
durch das ständige spucken von beeten
aus resten auf die brücke verursacht
werden
verbotsschilder sollen passanten davon
abbringen zu spucken doch die
geschätzten 500.000 fußgänger die
täglich über die brücke gehen halten
sich nicht daran
tatsächlich geht es auf der stahlbrücke
oft zu wie auf einer müllkippe täglich
versuchen mehrere putztrupps dagegen
anzukämpfen für die gesamte wartung der
brücke gibt die stadt kalkutta
umgerechnet 19.000 euro pro jahr aus für
indische verhältnisse ist das ein hohes
budget
wir müssen täglich den dreck von den
leuten weg machen
die putz männer auf der harbour bridge
haben einen harten job um sie herum
ständig abgase lärm und unberechenbare
fahrmanöver einige obdachlose leben
praktisch auf der brücke
gefährlich ist das nicht wirklich
allerdings bin ich schon ein paar mal
angefahren worden
die leute passen einfach überhaupt nicht
auf
das interessiert sie gar nicht dass wir
hier arbeiten
geschützt über
200.000 autos und bis zu zwei millionen
menschen passieren täglich die brücke
mehr geht nicht die brücke ist dafür
nicht gebaut und würde die belastung
nicht lange aushalten
das design der brücke ist sehr
ungewöhnlich denn die straße und ihre
gehwege werden anders als üblich nicht
über die gesamte länge der brücke
geführt sondern jenseits der pfeiler
seitlich zu den uferbereichen geleitet
die fahrbahn befindet sich daher nicht
im inneren des tragwerks sondern auf
einer eigenen fahrbahn tafel die
unterhalb der tragenden
brückenkonstruktion angehängt ist eine
sehr selten anzutreffende konstruktion
für die die erbauer aber im wahrsten
sinne des wortes an vielen fronten
kämpfen mussten
die herausforderung kam nicht nur von
der wasserseite einem reißenden fluss
sondern auch aus der luft ganz wichtig
denn während des baus brach der krieg
aus und die fertigstellung der brücke
fiel mitten in die hochphase
chaos von während der konstruktion die
1936 startete bei ausbruch des krieges
wurde der stahlbau nur knapp von einem
bombardement der japanischen
kriegsflotte verschont große teile der
stadt hatten weniger glück und wurden
zerstört
in der folge verzichtet die regierung
sogar auf eine einweihungszeremonie
alles und das indische pionierprojekt zu
schützen
wirklich ungefährlich ist es jahrzehnte
später auf der brücke immer noch nicht
wieder alltag der putz pro zeigt ein
abenteuerlicher hindernislauf
ok
immer wieder werden sie von autos oder
fahrrädern angefahren
doch eine etage höher wollen sie auch
nicht arbeiten
ich würde schon oben auf dem gerüst
arbeiten
immerhin gibt es ja mehr kohle aber
ehrlich gesagt wenn ich hoch schaue ist
es mir doch zu gefährlich
das team balanciert oben auf der brücke
um ein vogelnest zu entfernen komplett
ungesichert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die entsorgung ist dann auch eher
unkonventionell trotz aller gefahren der
job im wartungsteam ist sehr begehrt
ich bin stolz für die hoga bridge zu
arbeiten
ich dafür ein gewaltiges bauwerk
besser geht es doch nicht
ich liebe mein indien
die horror bridge in indien für viele
brücken fans ein wunderwerk der technik
für einige andere ein stahl monster das
an die grenzen seiner belastbarkeit
gekommen ist
die nächste stahlbrücke befindet sich in
nordamerika
267 meter über den juli wird ein
weiterer stahlgigant die new river gold
sprit nach drei jahren bauzeit wurde sie
1977 eröffnet die baukosten betrugen
damals 37 millionen dollar ihre
spannweite
580m
den übergang sprit liegt in den usa in
west virginia
täglich fahren bis zu 20.000 fahrzeuge
über die stahlbogenbrücke ist ständig
erschütterungen ausgesetzt und muss
daher regelmäßig gewartet werden
kälte ständige winde und ihre
gigantische höhe verlangen dem
wartungsteam alles ab
[Applaus]
30 grad - im winter in west virginia
keine seltenheit der fluss in der
schlucht und die abgeschiedenheit des
nationalparks machen die
wartungsarbeiten zu einer logistischen
herausforderung
regelmäßig rückt ein wartungsteam an
matthew allen und seine männer besteigen
die höchsten brücken im ganzen land
heute ist die new york dran man gewöhnt
sich zwar mit der zeit heran aber die
umstände sind doch jedes mal anders
manchmal ist es sehr windig so wie heute
das kann der einfluss wiederabstieg
verläuft manchmal wird mir zb von der
wand weggedrückt
ruhiger desto besser wenn es zu unruhig
wird brechen alles
keine leichten voraussetzungen für märz
schützling andrew denn der muss heute
als erster runter und obwohl er schon
einige kletter einsätze hatte die new
river gold brücke kinder nicht
die so weit runter wie du kannst
kein kletterer steigt ohne aufsicht über
die brüstung mindestens zwei kollegen
haben andrew zu jederzeit im blick super
weise mut macht den job schon seit 20
jahren er merkt sofort wenn etwas nicht
stimmt
erst mit diesem 200 pfund schweren saal
ist es anstrengend
zum ersten mal die neue waggons runter
die anspannung beim neueinsteiger ist
deutlich zu spüren
dabei fängt der job heute bewusst
einfach an erste aufgabe oberflächlicher
sichtkontrolle jeder winkel nun die der
ecke muss kontrolliert und dokumentiert
werden
seine beobachtungen über den zustand der
brücke notiert sich andrew auf seinem
tablett
[Musik]
und hier ist er wieder was hast du da
unten gesehen
sieht gut aus metz
als ich da unten war habe ich ein
bisschen oberflächen korrosion und rost
instinkt das ist nichts wildes
ich habe es notiert wir müssen es beim
nächsten mal im auge behalten dass es
nicht schlimmer wird
die schwierigste aufgabe hat das team
noch vor sich später müssen sie zwei
metallplatten der brücke verschieben
fast 300 meter über der schlucht direkt
unter der 162 tonnenschweren fahrbahn
früher oder später bringt die new river
gold jeden arbeiter an seine grenzen der
wind ist der schlimmste in dieser gegend
hörte einfach nie auf
chefingenieur jim juristen kennt die
brücke seit der grundsteinlegung
er erinnert sich noch genau daran wie
riskant der job schon damals war
die arbeiter waren extrem gut
ausgebildet es hat einen grund warum wir
sie die eisenmänner der schlucht nennen
bei jedem wetter waren sie da draußen es
ist ein wirklich harter job alle mit
denen ich darüber gesprochen habe haben
gesagt es war die härteste aber auch die
beste zeit ihres lebens
die überquerung der schlucht ist sehr
aufwendig noch dazu sollen sie etwas
sehr spezielles bauen sie entschieden
sich für diese einzigartige bogenbrücke
die erste ihrer art sie wäre für die
umgebung am besten geeignet für die
länge die tiefe der schlucht und die
einzigartigkeit der ganzen region
die bauweise dieser bogenbrücke ist zur
damaligen zeit bahnbrechend der größte
gegner die breite tiefe schlucht gründer
ingenieur michael brecker ließ die
brücke deshalb von rechts und links
aufeinander zu bauen stück für stück
wächst sie so zusammen bei ihrer
fertigstellung
1977 ist sie mit 518 metern bogen
spannweite weltweit die größte ihrer art
der bau in dieser höhe um über diese
große distanz ist damals nur durch eine
einmalige kabel kran konstruktion
möglich so können die einzelnen
brückenelemente präzise positioniert
werden
als ingenieur schaut man immer auf den
kosten-nutzen-faktor in den frühen 70ern
machte dieser faktor überhaupt keinen
sinn warum sollte man ausgerechnet in
dieser zeit eine 40 millionen dollar
brücke bauen aber die leute hatten eine
vision sie waren vorausschauend und
haben erkannt dass es sich auszahlen
wird die visionen zahlen sich aus über
die alte umgehungsstraße dauert der weg
von einer zur anderen seite der schlucht
45 minuten über die new river gold
brücke nur noch 40 sekunden
das ergebnis ein enormer
wirtschaftlicher aufschwung in der nun
viel besser angebundenen region
täglich rollen sich tausende fahrzeuge
über die brücke vor allem im winter ein
problem aggressives streusalz ist gift
für die brückenkonstruktion
deshalb verwenden die ingenieure kalzium
magnesium acetat ein schonender
streusalz ersatz mit geringem
gefrierpunkt die brücke ist extrem
wartungsintensiv verschiedenen teams
sind regelmäßig im einsatz matt und
seine ingenieure machen sich bereit für
die hauptaufgabe des tages unter der
fahrbahn direkt über der schlucht die
einzige sicherung ein lockeres sein
nach einigen sichtkontrollen folgt die
größte herausforderung für heute ein
tragendes element der brücke muss bei
laufendem verkehr verschoben werden
klingt eigentlich unmöglich ist es aber
nicht
eine markierung stimmt dieser streifen
muss ihre über uns dann sollte alles
wieder stimmen
der mittlere teil der brücke dehnt sich
je nach temperatur aus oder zieht sich
zusammen
1 der brückenlager das für den nötigen
spielraum sorgt hat sich verhakt und
muss in position gebracht werden
[Applaus]
genau das wollten wir wir mussten sehen
wie es sich bewegt das heißt es hat sich
vom bogen gelöst und ihr können das
problem das bewegen
der druck aus dem kompressor unterstützt
die männer und nimmt gewicht von der
platte so wird das brückenlager
beweglichen kann sich wieder einrenken
die höhe des drucks die auswahl und
positionierung der geräte jetzt zeigt
sich ob andrews berechnungen richtig
sind
ja ich bin zufrieden alles ist gut
gegangen alles wo es hingehört
alles verlief nach plan wir haben es
circa acht zentimeter verschoben
diese markierungen sind jetzt in einer
linie alles stimmt wieder es passt
perfekt das brückenlager und damit das
tragende element ist wieder in der
perfekten position
dabei hat sich die gesamte wartung unter
der brücke am gespielt und zwar wären
oben auf der vierspurigen fahrbahn der
verkehr reibungslos weiter geflossen ist
nur einmal im jahr wird die brücke für
den autoverkehr gesperrt während des so
genannten bric days im oktober sind
fallschirmsprünge von der brücke
china ist auf dem weg zum bedeutendsten
brücken land der welt zu werden ein
beispiel dafür steht in der mega
metropole chongqing
mit 30 millionen einwohnern eine der
größten städte der welt mittendrin die
schau die an männel c brücke
sie wurde 2009 eröffnet und hat 552
meter spannweite rekord unter
bogenbrücken
die jangtse brücke liegt in südwestchina
gefertigt aus massivem stahl führt sie
rund 1700 meter über den berühmten
jangtse-fluss
ein architektonischer weltrekord und ein
highlight auf dass die chinesen zu recht
stolz sind
aufgrund der hohen belastung und der
ständigen erschütterungen muss die
brücke ständig kontrolliert und gewartet
werden auch bei widrigsten bedingungen
[Musik]
schon die bauarbeiten sprengten alle
dimensionen
denn so ein projekt gab es noch nie
zuvor ein stahlgigant mitten in der
mega-city chongqing
die chinesische metropole wird durch den
jangtse-fluss geteilt damit die bewohner
schneller von a nach b kommen gibt es
nur eine lösung
die schau die brücke mit einer
gesamtlänge von
1441 metern und der spannweite von
552 meter brechen die chinesen rekorde
liu vice president der chongqing city
construction group war bei den
bauarbeiten dabei und kennt daher die
herausforderungen
schon alleine wegen der lage mussten wir
den bogen der brücke so groß bauen
das problem es gab keinerlei erfahrungen
wie sich material in dieser größe
verhält
das waren unglaubliche ansprüche an die
belastbarkeit der gesamten brücke
im dezember 2004 beginnt der bau der
schau die am ende nur gut vier jahre
später ist sie fertig kostenpunkt
umgerechnet circa 420 millionen euro
[Musik]
7 uhr 30 das team um chefinspektor
joline bereitet sich auf den einsatz vor
ein gewisses risiko ist bei unserer
arbeit immer dabei ganz einfach weil wir
meistens in extremen höhen arbeiten
angst habe ich aber keine
hoffentlich sind wir mit der wartung
fertig bevor das wetter allzu schlecht
ist
das sechsköpfige wartungsteam macht sich
auf den weg trotz dauerregens
doch bevor die truppe auf die brücke
geht muss sie zunächst die arbeiten im
unteren teil der brücke checken extreme
belastungen erfordern außergewöhnliche
brückenkonstruktionen
[Musik]
die steinbrücke ist eine besondere
fachwerk brücke drei verstrebungen
ergeben die typischer
fachwerkkonstruktion
allerdings sind die einzel streben
unterschiedlich breit und tief dort wo
nach den berechnungen größere
belastungen auftreten werden dann auch
größere querschnitte oder mit mehr
material benötigt
eine weitere besonderheit die brücke ist
zweistöckig
im unteren teil der brücke sollten
eigentlich auto schon züge fahren
allerdings sind die baumaßnahmen noch
nicht abgeschlossen trotzdem muss auch
der untere teil der brücke ständig
gewartet werden ansonsten wären die
schäden sehr schnell sehr groß
eine stahlbrücke fängt einfach immer
schnell an zu rosten
deswegen müssen wir ständig den stahl
bearbeiten um möglichst wenig
korrosionsschäden an der brücke zur an
die männer arbeiten direkt über den
abgrund zum ihre
schleifen und lackieren im akkord alles
um langzeitschäden zu vermeiden wenig
später stehen eine etage höher oben auf
der brücke noch viel schwierigere
wartungsarbeiten an das wetter hat sich
verschlechtert doch müssen schichtführer
solide und seine männer gleich einen
gefährlichen aufstieg angehen
leute seid bitte vorsichtig arbeitet
konzentriert last nichts fallen schaut
ob etwas aus ihren taschen fahren kann
und checkt noch mal eure sicherheitsgurt
männer wollen
die crew musste flugzeug waren leuchten
prüfen die sehr weit oben an der bogen
spitze der brücke angebracht sind
der aufstieg ist über 200 meter lang
eine wirkliche sicherung ist erst
während der arbeit möglich nicht aber
beim aufstieg
das große problem
das wetter wird noch schlechter durch
den monsun regen wird die gigantische
stahlbrücke schnell zur unberechenbaren
enorm rutschigen gefahr doch noch wollen
die männer ihre inspektion unbedingt
durchziehen
was uns heute echt extremen bedingungen
die handschuhe sind das alles ist
rutschig aber wir müssen unsere arbeit
jetzt sorgfältig fertig machen
nur minuten später verschlechtert sich
das wetter allerdings nochmal rapide
unmengen wasser kommen runter nicht
ungewöhnlich in der monsunzeit jetzt
weiter zu gehen wäre lebensgefährlich
abbruch wer heute geht nichts mehr ende
eines arbeitstags wie es über dem
jangtse immer mal vorkommen kann
zum glück funktioniert die riesige
blinkt anlage einwandfrei und warnt die
flugzeuge vor der schau die an brücke
die nächste brücke steht in japan
gewaltig und gleichzeitig elegant die
hiroshima flughafenbrücke die 2010
eröffnete brücke ist mit 195 metern die
höchste in ganz japan die hiroshima
flughafenbrücke ist teil des central
flight highways der die region mit dem
flughafen hiroshima verbindet mit 380
metern ist sie eine der längsten
fachwerk bogenbrücken der bau dauerte
zehn jahre und heute noch stellt die
brücke diejenigen die an ihre arbeiten
vor ganz besondere herausforderungen
der flughafen von hiroshima 3 millionen
passagiere starten und landen hier jedes
jahr ein wichtiges verkehrsdrehkreuz die
meisten passagiere kommen aus dem norden
um zum flughafen zu gelangen mussten sie
früher den fluss mutter kompliziert
passieren bis 2010 die brücke gebaut
wird seitdem hat sich die fahrt zum
flughafen um 20 minuten verkürzt
damit die fahrt sicher ist muss die
brücke ständig geprüft und gewartet
werden überall entlang des stahlkoloss
verlaufen treppen für den einstieg
heute steht der große check an
die 25-jährige kawano ist das erste mal
dabei allerdings hat sie schon einige
kleine inspektionen auf der brücke
absolviert und weiß worauf es ankommt
wir steigen jetzt gleich die leiter
runter um eine sicht inspektion auf der
brücke durchzuführen ob irgendwelche
bolzen oder muttern locker sind oder ob
frost entstanden ist
[Musik]
die große inspektionsrunde auf der
brücke ist im fünf jahres rhythmus
vorgeschrieben heute steht sie erstmals
an
bei der begehung des gigantischen
bauwerks haben kawano und ihre kollegen
eine ganz klare reihenfolge
[Musik]
ferner gehört
wenn ich die inspektion mache dann bin
ich fokussiert und schalte alles
drumherum aus
aber es gibt momente in denen ich
einfach den ausblick genießen
und dann denke ich mir ich habe
jetzt das uns weitermachen ist noch auf
den bogen für eine inspektion
gebogen ist das herzstück der brücke
schließlich zählt er mit 380 metern
spannbreite auch zu den längsten der
welt und mit 195 metern ist die brücke
zudem ziemlich hoch ähnlich wie die new
river gold sprit warum die japanischen
ingenieure die brücke von links und
rechts gleichzeitig dabei müssen sie
exakt kalkulieren damit der bogen der
brücke in der mitte genau
zusammengesetzt werden kann die
unglaublich geringe abweichung von 16
millimetern am ende gleicht einer
meisterleistung ein spezieller kran soll
die teile stück für stück in die höhe
bringt das problem normale motoren sind
für den knappen zeitplan zu langsam wie
in der gewaltigen lasten die japanischen
ingenieure greifen auf einen speziellen
motor aus deutschland zurück der die bis
zu 30 tonnen schweren teile viel
schneller positionieren kann
kenny cooper senior engineer der
hiroshima airport bridge erinnert sich
an einige große herausforderungen beim
bau
wegen der enormen höhe der brücke hätte
auch eine kleine schraube die
herunterfällt einen großen schaden bei
passanten oder den zügen verursachen
können
um das zu verhindern haben wir zeitweise
ein netz gespannt und immer dorthin
bewegt wo wir gerade gearbeitet
schließlich kann die fahrbahn auf den
boden gesetzt werden doch nicht nur die
höhe bringt das bauteam in bedrängnis
ständig muss die arbeit unterbrochen
werden aus sicherheitsgründen
[Musik]
die brücke führt über eine normale
straße und eine bahnstrecke und die bahn
fährt in zehn bis 15 minuten
beim bau der brücke musste mir ständig
den zeitplan der bahnen checken und
unsere arbeit direkt über den gleisen
unterbrechen
deswegen war es enorm schwierig in der
geplanten zeit fertig zu werden
unterhalb der brücke verläuft eine
bahnstrecke aus sicherheitsgründen
musste für jeden durchfahrenden zug die
arbeit unterbrochen werden
oben auf der brücke eine weitere
besonderheit eine fahrspur endet
sozusagen im nichts sie wird heute nur
für die wartungs fahrzeuge genutzt
für die inspektions crew geht es heute
ohne unterbrechung weiter sie sind auf
dem weg zum bogen der brücke ein
ziemlich beschwerlicher aufstieg
[Musik]
halte die mir bitte die leiter ich gehe
als erster auf für den job müssen wir
fit sein geklettert viel es geht an die
kondition
kurios der aufstieg erinnert an eine
klettertour und ist tatsächlich
improvisiert denn beim bau der mega
brücke wurde schlichtweg ein weg zum
bogen vergessen der soll noch
nachträglich gebaut werden
schließlich hat es die kronach
beschwerlichen 20 minuten geschafft sie
ist auf dem brückenbogen start der
sichtkontrolle
ab jetzt gibt es leiter und treppen doch
auch von hier aus geht es noch weit nach
oben am gesamten bogen sucht die crew
nach lackschäden oder losen schrauben
bis jetzt ist alles gut schavan hat es
bald geschafft
[Musik]
es ist wirklich nicht meine
lieblingsbeschäftigung in solche höhen
zu klettern
aber der ausblick von hier ist super und
es ist eine wunderschöne brücke
wir sind fast 180 meter über dem abgrund
damit ist die hiroshima flughafenbrücke
die höchste brücke die jemals in japan
gebaut wurde und ganz sicher eine der
spektakulärsten stahlbrücken der welt
[Musik]